so like I said my name is Tanner Linsley
from Utah and I love JavaScript so much
I also love react even more I'm happy to
be able to talk about react at a
JavaScript conference I'm on github
probably way too much writing way too
many open-source libraries I'm also on
Twitter and YouTube so you can come say
hi to me there if you want I know that
you're all probably feeling like you
can't see my screen yeah you're probably
feeling a little bit like my son here
you know just really tired and wanting
to consume that last little bit of
JavaScript just do your best you know
that it's I know it's hard but we're
gonna make it through it together
because today I'm talking about react
hooks and more specifically custom react
hooks and I'm so excited about this I
hope you are too
I know it's been a noisy year you guys
probably feel like whether you're
whether you love react or not you
probably feel this way so I'm gonna do
my best today to make sure that this is
not just another react hoaxes tutorial
it's going to be fast because I have a
lot of content to go over and there's
going to be a lot of code hopefully it's
a lot of fun I'm gonna be saying use a
lot so it's hard it's a tongue twister
you'll see so before we get into my the
bulk of my talk let's go through react
hooks basics really quickly classes are
out we no longer write with classes
everything is just a function now and
that is so nice it makes us so that
components that used to look like this
to use state don't have to look like
that anymore we can just use use state
it's so much better in my opinion where
we can use use reducer class life cycles
are no longer a thing oh I'm so glad to
be done with these things also we don't
have to do manual change detection
anymore
with the old class life cycles we can
just use the use of fact function from
react passes some dependencies and
everything will just synchronize for us
it also comes built-in with memoization
and can
to state and things around memorizing
values and functions where before we
could do this with react before but now
it's built in so we can make sure that
we're only computing or doing work when
we need to be doing it and last the most
important thing that I'd like to talk
about today is custom hooks which a
custom hook is really just a function
that runs inside of a component that can
run other hooks or other functions like
use state use reduce or whatever and
they can be recursive they can go
forever you can have a custom hook call
another custom hook calling it a custom
hook call another custom hook and
everything will just come back in and it
just works it's amazing
it makes us so patterns like this that
before we had to nest all these
callbacks and create higher-order
components and render props and you know
functions as children all that gets to
go away and we're simply left with a
couple of function calls that we can
make inside of our inside of our
components custom hooks are so powerful
I believe that they give us a couple
more affordances that we didn't have
when we were using class components I
think that they encouraged us to build
our own solutions because it makes
building our own solutions easier the
API is more expressive I also believe
that building hook's custom hooks way
more portable and shareable than
building custom components and trying to
move logic around with components the
other great thing is that custom hooks
can be component aware and abstract
essentially anything that we want them
to this makes them very powerful for
integrating with essentially anything we
want to integrate with the outset in the
outside world away from react and last
but not least I think that they highly
encourage rapid iteration for some of
the reasons that I'm going to talk about
today so the biggest reason that I
believe that all those things are true
is that hooks they with the introduction
of custom hooks I think that we're going
to see or have already seen a return to
components handling user interface and
hooks handling business logic and if
this seems like a no-brainer you're
ahead of the curve and if it doesn't
that's what I'd like to talk about today
through so many migrations of old
projects to hooks going 100
hooks and new greenfield projects where
I was able to experiment with new
patterns around custom hooks and see you
know how far can we push the limits of
this new API I've discovered a couple of
use cases that have really sparked new
interest for me with this hooks API
most of them around building portable UI
utilities a few of them well actually a
lot of them around managing global state
and server state and also encapsulating
business logic for our applications
inside of these custom hooks and I want
to share with you a couple of these use
cases today to show you how custom hooks
can really change the way that you think
about writing your applications and to
be more productive why not start off
with something that is so hot right now
you can't ship an app without it and
it's sometimes it's the first thing that
we all think about probably the most
important thing we all think about
that's dark mode you can't ship without
it right this is so hot right now
everybody wants a dark mode you know
everybody's got that toggle at the top
of their site you go between light and
dark mode it's pretty easy to do you can
just set up some state and toggle
between it with a function set is dark
to true or false it's really that easy I
wanted something a little more
sophisticated for my dark mode I don't
know if you guys have ever seen
match media but it's an API that you can
use to match CSS media queries in
JavaScript and detect certain things
about the users environment right here
we have a match media that's detecting
whether the user prefers a light or a
dark theme and we can actually set up
our state to start with that so that if
the user has a darker light theme
preference on their device our state now
starts with that preference and they can
toggle between it but who has this
enabled on their computer this auto mode
I do and I love it and I thought
wouldn't it be amazing if we could make
it so our light and dark themes would
actually react to that automatic mode on
our devices turns out it's not too hard
we can take an effect and
put our match media inside it and listen
to changes to that match media and
update our dark variable whenever that
changes and if we put all that together
inside of our app right here it's all
just handled for us now the Sun sets we
go into dark mode the Sun rises we go
into light mode it's actually pretty fun
to play with but the problem I see here
is that a lot of this logic is now
taking up space in my app component and
I don't really like that talking about
clean code opinions here but this I see
is a great example of where we can make
our first custom hook we can actually
just take all that logic and rip it out
into its own file we'll call it use dark
mode and everything in here is exactly
the same except for we're returning is
dark at the very end and that makes this
use dark mode hook extremely versatile
in our app now we can import that file
call use dark mode and it's going to
give us true or false but it's not just
true or false
it's true or false that changes over
time and all of the lifecycle and
updating and all of the intelligence of
that dark mode is built into that hook
and all we have to do is call it and
that is our first custom hood for today
that's when everybody gloves
so the next thing that I thought every
application needs
everybody has written this a thousand
times clicking outside of an element and
I don't know why the browser's don't
make it easier to do this Nate natively
but you know I feel like I'm
implementing this every day clicking
outside of a menu or a modal or whatever
right and then you want to do something
to it I thought what about you know
there's not a better excuse to write a
custom component for this and I thought
we might as well just make the
assumption that this is going to be a
custom hook right out of the gate so I
assumed that I could take a ref created
by user F put it on to whatever element
I want to keep track of and then have a
handle or something like you know
console logging hey you clicked outside
of this thing and I could pass those two
things to this used click outside hook
and it would just work and I wrote this
actually before I wrote the use click
outside hook to see how reliable it was
to design API surround hooks before even
writing him it turns out it wasn't too
difficult we start with the function
signature we throw in an effect that's
going to set up our event listeners on
the document for when we click on the
document those call our internal
listener here that checks to see if the
target we clicked is inside of the
element that we're tracking and if it
isn't it calls our callback turns out it
just works and we would probably use
this for a little bit and think wow this
is great I'm a genius but eventually you
might notice something very strange
there's something fishy going on here
and it has to do with the use effects
dependencies now if you're using the
eslint plugin react hooks which you
should be 99% of the time it does
exactly what you want it to it auto
fills affected dependencies for your
hooks it's so helpful I love it you can
just hit save and if you have a yes
let's setup it will just do the changes
for you and that's what it did here when
we built our hook here on the right you
can see it automatically filled in the
callback and the L ref down there in our
dependencies but the problem is that the
callback is changing every single render
from where we're using it on the left
side here on click outside we're
creating it every single time which
means that those event listeners are
firing off every single time that we
render we're adding and removing
event listeners that is not cool well it
turns out it's pretty easy to just wrap
that and use call back from react and
it's going to make it so that that
callback function doesn't change unless
the dependencies change there are no
dependencies yet so nothing's going to
change and it will stop you know
creating those event listeners over and
over and over but this begs the question
for me why why do I have to have that
use callback around that function this
is probably an advanced edge case but I
feel like there's nothing inside of my
use click outside hook that cares about
this callback changing and I decided
that that's part of the API so I wanted
to get rid of it and one of the easiest
ways to do that is to instead of
referencing the callback directly we can
use this pattern of tracking the latest
version of that callback in a ref itself
and when we do that the callback ref is
now added to the dependency array which
will never change but the value that we
hold inside it will and that way we're
only setting up and tearing down that
event listener when we actually need to
when the element that we're tracking
actually changes so now there's no
callback we can pass whatever function
we want into that use click outside hook
and that is our second custom hood for
today what's fantastic about this is you
can move this around your app you can
import it to as many components as you
want or you can just copy and paste this
into another app there's no external
dependencies other than react and I do
this all the time Greenfield project I'm
like oh I really love that hook I go
back to the last project that I was
working on I open the file I copy it and
I move it over it's that easy I don't
even really rely on external libraries
so do a lot of this stuff because it's
just so simple that's something that
isn't simple is state state is as
particularly global state
global state is highly opinionated
there's a new way to manage global State
everyday comes out there's a new library
it's kind of noisy and we're gonna be
talking a lot about global state here
for the last part of this talk global
state in my opinion is something that's
always trying to
help you it's because you think you have
a handle on it and then your your
requirements change and everything
changes in your app and it kind of pulls
the rug out from underneath you this is
usually how global State starts and
you're like wow this is so simple I have
a hook it's going to return some global
state theoretically and then for some
reason it can quickly turn into
something like this not to name names or
anything but this is something I would
try and avoid I don't I don't want to
have to go to these links to use global
State so I'm going to take you on a
little bit of a journey of finding
global State today
and it's going to be so introspective
and enlightening that maybe you'll want
to actually handle your own global State
after today let's start by creating a
global store we can use react context to
pass values down our react tree not have
to pass them through props we can start
with a store provider that's just a
wrapper around context that will set up
some state with a store with a store and
asset store function right there that we
can pass down through our context value
and then we'll have a use store custom
hook that just wraps around that use
context and what that does is it now
inside of our app we can declare some
initial state pass that initial state
into our store provider and now that
state is going to be available to all
the components inside of it including
the little - duze component down there
and inside of a instead of our
components we can consume the store
pretty easily by just calling you store
which gives us the current state of the
store and a way to update it which right
now is just set state set States kind of
boring though and it's a prone to break
and I don't really feel good about
manipulating the store directly from a
component so what if we took it a step
further to use reducer use reducer is
really pretty simple to use in my
opinion just create a reducer function
here we can do it in our app we can pass
that reducer function into our store
provider we created and instead of used
State now we can just use reducer
passively reduce through the initial
state and instead of a set state
function to directly modify the store
now
a dispatcher we can use so in our
components instead of importing the set
state we get the dispatch and now we can
dispatch actions and have a little bit
more confidence about the actions that
are taking place inside of our app
especially for even four components like
an individual to do where we're not
necessarily reading from the store but
just dispatching we can still import
just we can still import the store and
get a hold of dispatcher to send off
some events this pattern is really
simple it will probably get you pretty
far but at the end of the day might
bring up questions about unnecessary
renders you know I'm rear end during
every component in my app every single
time that the state changes even if I'm
only dispatching well it turns out we
can use a concept called multiple
context to aid this a little bit multi
context a multi context global store was
first introduced to me by my friend Kent
C Dodds
and he's made a popular through a couple
of blog posts which are just fantastic
and it describes creating two separate
contexts for your store and your
dispatcher and sending them both down
the down the line and creating another
use dispatch custom hook there so now
inside of our components if we want the
store we use the use store hook and if
we want the dispatcher we use they use
dispatch hook this makes it so that in
components that are only using the
dispatcher they're not going to get
updated every single time to store
updates and that will get rid of a lot
of weird unnecessary renders around that
scenario let's take it a step further
what about a single store is probably
not going to scale for very long if you
have a lot of global state in your
application you don't want every single
component updating when this state that
you're consuming updates that global
State so we can take it a step further
with multiple stores we can take all of
that logic that we had to create our
global store and just wrap it into a
function and we can create as many of
these global stores as we want by
passing them in a reducer in initial
state so if we wanted to do store we
just pass it the to do reducer it gives
us back the provider and a couple of
hooks to consume it and we're off to the
races we come into our app we provide
our traduced
the entire app and you know what I want
some Louisville state to manage all of
my menus being open and stuff like that
so I'll make a layout store as well and
I'll wrap that around my app and then
inside of our component like our menu
that we wanted to click outside and have
it you know change around we can hook it
up to that use layout store by both
subscribing to the store to see if it's
open and the dispatcher to make sure
that we can toggle it closed when we
click outside of it
the next step in our journey is
persistence right now our global store
isn't really persisting anything this is
extremely important because your users
are going to reload the page and
everything's going to disappear so let's
throw in some local storage local
storage is pretty easy to use especially
if you're using a reducer so right here
we can instantiate our reducer
initial-value from local storage and
also every time a reducer runs we can
save the resulting state into local
storage using a key and now every single
time that your users reload the page
they're going to get the last state that
they were left with I know this is where
you guys want to be and I'm working hard
to get you there just to make sure that
everybody is awake like that I got some
t-shirts all right
moving on what about remote data
persistence so local storage is great
but eventually users are going to want
some remote data persistence they're
gonna want to store their data on a
server they're gonna want things to sync
between their devices they're so
entitled so let's talk about server
state now I say server state because I
believe that it is truly different from
global state but it is the same in
spirit server state introduces some
interesting challenges around moving
from synchronous api's to asynchronous
api's we're no longer interacting with a
store or a dispatcher we are interacting
with you know fetching assets and
sending mutations or queries to the
server and expecting them to do things
right and along along with that we're
gonna notice that a lot of our
components where we'd previously wired
up things like dispatch in the store
that kind of becomes a little bit of a
question mark now where are we getting
those things well turns out that our
components are really great places to
compose business logic and user
interface together and this can be so
easy that sometimes it's a detriment we
take things like local state markup you
at UI events Styles things that I feel
are meant to be in components and we
kind of mix them together with all this
state and these external utilities or
maybe expensive computation or or side
effects that are happening on servers
right and we take all that when we
smoosh it together inside of our
components and sometimes it can make
them easy to hard to reason about and
I'd like to propose a new pattern today
where we need to remember that custom
hooks are free now there's no cost of
adding a new custom hood other than the
cost of abstraction you can ask Kent C
Dodds what he how he feels about the
cost of abstraction he talks about it a
lot but today I'd like to introduce a
new layer of abstraction to our journey
they're just custom hooks there's really
nothing to say other than that and
they're going to proxy
all of our business logic between our
components and the external services and
the external features that we want to
integrate with them so in this case
we're going to take our two dews
component we're going to write a use two
dews custom hook that's going to do all
the heavy lifting for us between our
data what would that look like we could
just start with a use to do we can
import used seduced into our component
and just expect that it returns to Deus
and that would be enough for now
this used to deuce hook could do
whatever we wanted to as long as it
returns to deuce that's all we care
about the implementation details are
hidden from the component it doesn't
care and it shouldn't so if we wanted to
implement our existing in-memory store
we could just import our memories our
store and return the - duze from it and
we would be fine but remember we need to
talk about asynchronous state and state
coming from the server that changes a
lot of things especially if we're not
talking about suspense which is a whole
other talk but let's assume that we're
not using suspense and this is what
something like that would look like we
know that it's going to be loading at
some point we know there could be an
error or we know we could have to do and
as long as we conform to this function
signature we can actually do a lot with
this custom hook this used to dus custom
hook that we just made we could use an
effect and like a tool like Axios to
communicate with a rest server that
would load our traduz for us and we can
manage all of the you know the loading
state and everything ourselves or we
could use a very common hook called a
used promise that will let us pass a
function that returns a promise and
handle all of that is loading in error
State for us again as long as we're
returning the to do is the loading state
in the error any component that's
consuming to do this isn't really going
to care and you know we could do the
same thing take this pattern and apply
the same pattern to anything doing a
mutation so if we had you know a to do
component that was going to toggle
something we could have that used toggle
to do custom hook take care of that for
us
so instead of importing you know some
rest api or you know Axios directly
inside of our component we import use
toggle to do we call it and it'll give
us a func
you know instead of just giving us
function let's assume it's going to be
asynchronous it'll give us a function
and the loading state and error state as
well and again that unlocks us to do and
unlocks us the ability to do whatever we
want in that you STOVL to do hook we can
do whatever we want as long as we're
returning a function that the component
can call and an is loading an air state
so we could use our in-memory store
again and just hook it right up to our
to-do store is loading an error is false
and all all the time if we're doing this
or we can go into the rest into the rest
paradigm and just use Axios to you know
issue off some type of a post command to
to our server to toggle this to do but
you know this can get pretty I know this
can get pretty confusing very quickly if
you're if you're managing all these side
effects especially when we start
thinking about things like caching what
happens when we're using these custom
hooks multiple times in our app if we
need to do Xin multiple places are they
separate copies are we you know
reduplicating things are we creating
race conditions and if we're caching
when are we fetching that data you know
what there are so many questions that
happen along there well we don't have to
stop there are used to dues a custom
hook can doesn't have to communicate
directly with our server it could use
other hooks as well there's a library
created called react query that helps
with scenarios like this you can use
react query to give it a function that
returns a promise it'll handle caching
and invalidation and make sure that
you're only you know you're not
duplicating to Do's across your entire
app even if you use it multiple times
and you'll notice that the really cool
part is that our return signature is
exactly the same so we just moved from
this weird funky promise based way of
fetching our data to something like
react query and all of our components
that use that use the used to do so
didn't have to change at all it's just
an implementation detail same thing we
could do for the mutations we could add
in react query for the use toggle to do
and in fact react query handles
react query handles a lot of the
invalidation for mutations so running
this mutation would invalidate all of
the other queries on the page
getting to Do's and it would cause all
of them to update it's not very
unsimilar to tools like Apollo and I
don't use graph QL a whole lot but when
I do I do enjoy using Apollo and you
know what would it take to switch to
something like Apollo well we could
import Apollo and make a query use the
use query hook from Apollo and again
we're just returning to dues is loading
an error we just moved from react query
to Apollo we didn't have to change
anything in our entire app so the same
thing with the causing a mutation you
know as long as we're returning that
toggle to do and is loading error again
our mutations don't have to change so we
were able to you know just in the last
five minutes well go from in memory
management of our data to promises to
react query in Apollo we can probably
even move to relay if we want it all
because we're using this this pattern of
creating your own custom hooks to
abstract our own business logic in our
apps away from our components to make
them smarter and to make them more
reliable this pattern to me is extremely
powerful
I see basically all the time in my
applications all my components are
communicating with custom hooks to
handle most of their business logic
which are then reaching out to possibly
even more custom hooks or external API
or whatever this creates a really nice
encapsulation around you know what is
user interface what is business logic
and what are the services I'm trying to
use in my applications thinking in this
thinking from this perspective you can
start to imagine so many great custom
hooks that you would want to use inside
of your apps but maybe not something
that would be shareable outside of your
app you know it's okay if a custom hook
is proprietary to something you're
working on if it makes you more
productive so these custom hooks and the
idea of custom hooks
so powerful I I take things to the
extreme and I create tons of open-source
libraries built on custom hooks those
four are just a few of them
reiax table is in fact just a hook it
actually doesn't render anything for you
it just as a hook that gives you
everything you need to render your own
table it's a really interesting concept
but my hope and invitation to all of you
today is to look at your hooks in your
apps and think of ways that you can make
yourself more agile abstract your
business logic into your custom hooks
and make your components dumber thereby
making them smarter
so be sure to check me out github
Twitter YouTube come talk to me I'd love
to chat and can't forget nozzle dot IO
that's my company they I started back in
Utah we build marketing software that
helps agencies know where they rank in
Google so thanks
[Applause]